Je suis fatiguée de faire semblant d'aller bien.
Une amie m'a dit que je suis fauchée mais pas indigente, nuance !
Je n'ai ni télé, ni d'abonnement à un club de sport,
aucune manucure prévue.
J'ai découvert que je peux me couper les cheveux.
Je n'ai aucune épargne-retraite,
aucun argent de côté.
Je l'ai épuisé il y a bien longtemps.
Je n'ai aucun appartement qui apporte une rente,
et aucun mari pour aider mes finances.
Des mois de remboursements en retard ou en défaut ont décimé mes économies.
Des agents de recouvrement m'appellent sans cesse,
lisant leur texte à la lettre
avant d'exprimer leur sympathie polie pour ma détresse
et continuer d'exiger un remboursement que je ne peux pas honorer.
Mes amis se demandent secrètement comment une personne munie d'une bonne formation
peut être en situation de détresse économique.
J'ai toujours beaucoup de talent, je suis toujours aussi maligne,
mais le travail est devenu rare,
principalement des petits contrats de consultance.
À 55 ans, j'ai appris à avoir l'air réjoui,
mais les opportunités de travail ne sont plus si fréquentes.
Je ne me souviens plus précisément quand la source s'est tarie,
mais je ne peux plus nier avoir passé le seuil
du monde précaire des has-been.
Je ne sais plus quelle est ma communauté.
Je sais simplement que les dizaines d'offres de recrutement en ligne
semblent s'évanouir dans un trou noir.
Je me demande ce qui va m'arriver.
Pour le moment, je reste en bonne santé,
mais j'ai mal partout, ou bien est-ce mon esprit qui a mal ?
Les femmes sans abri étaient invisibles jusqu'à présent.
Mais maintenant, je les observe avec un regard curieux,
me demandant si leur histoire a commencé comme la mienne.
J'ai dessiné ça il y a un an.
C'est une composition sur mon récit et celui d'autres femmes que je connais.
Je l'ai dessinée car j'étais fatiguée
de faire semblant que tout allait bien quand ce n'était pas le cas.
J'étais fatiguée de simuler la normalité.
Je ne me voyais pas dans la presse populaire.
Personne autour de moi ne voyage autour du monde ou n'achète de loft au Costa Rica.
Peu de mes amis ont mis de côté les 15 à 20 %
que les experts nous affirment être nécessaires
pour conserver notre niveau de vie après la retraite.
Mes amis, dans la cinquantaine ou la soixantaine,
sont face à une régression professionnelle,
ont un boulot alimentaire ;
il suffirait d'une perte d'emploi, d'une maladie ou d'un divorce
pour qu'ils deviennent insolvables.
On n'a pas encore touché le fond,
mais nous sommes nombreux à entrevoir une séquence d'événements
où les bas-fonds sont envisageables pour la première fois.
En fait, il n'en faut pas beaucoup.
Le ménage moyen aux États-Unis
a assez d'économies pour couvrir un mois de revenus.
47% d'entre nous
sont incapables de trouver 400 dollars pour gérer une urgence.
C'est presque la moitié d'entre nous.
Des réparation importantes sur la voiture et on est au bord du précipice.
Impossible de le détecter ainsi,
mais je ne suis pas la seule dans cette situation.
Certains parmi vous dans la salle sont dans cette situation.
Si ce n'est pas vous,
il peut s'agir de vos parents, de votre sœur, ou de votre meilleur ami.
On devient bon pour faire semblant que tout va bien.
La honte nous pousse au silence et nous isole.
Quand j'ai décidé de raconter mon histoire,
j'ai monté un site Web
et une amie a remarqué qu'il n'y avait aucune photo de moi,
rien que des dessins comme celui-ci.
Même au moment de mon coming-out,
je restais cachée.
Nous vivons dans un monde où le succès se mesure à l'aune de nos revenus.
Quand on évoque des problèmes financiers,
on annonce en fait qu'on est un loser.
Si comme moi, vous êtes diplômés de Harvard,
vous êtes doublement un loser.
On serine aux baby-boomers qu'ils ont sous-alimenté leur épargne-retraite.
C'est de notre faute.
Pourquoi diable devrions-nous recourir à notre épargne-retraite
pour payer les frais de maison de retraite de notre belle-mère,
pour payer les frais scolaires ou simplement pour survivre ?
On nous accuse de ne pas avoir planifié correctement, d'être bon à rien.
Tout cet argent dépensé en café et eau minérale !
Délicieuse est la tentation d'humiliation et de trouver un responsable.
On n'attend même pas à ce que d'autre le fasse,
on se l'inflige à soi-même.
Je l'avoue,
on aurait tous pu épargner un peu plus.
Je sais que j'aurais pu épargner plus.
Si vous épluchez les 30 dernières années de ma vie,
vous constaterez que j'ai pris quelques mauvaises décisions financières.
Je ne peux plus revenir en arrière,
et vous non plus.
Mais ne mélangeons pas les comportements individuels
avec les facteurs systémiques
qui sont la cause du trou de 7,7 milliards de dollars.
Des millions de baby-boomers américains ne sont pas arrivés à cette situation
à cause de trop de détours au Starbucks.
On gère depuis trente ans des salaires stables ou décroissants,
des retraites qui s'évaporent,
et des coûts astronomiques
de logement, de santé et de scolarité.
Ça n'a pas toujours été ainsi.
On se souvient tous des trois piliers des revenus de la retraite
couverts par l'épargne, la retraite et la sécurité sociale.
Ces piliers avaient des pieds d'argile.
Prenez les économies.
Pour de nombreuses familles,
il ne reste plus rien pour épargner une fois que les factures sont payées.
L'épargne-retraite aussi est fragile.
On se souvient de l'époque où la plupart des gens recevaient une retraite.
Or, aujourd'hui, 13% seulement des travailleurs américains
ont un employeur qui offre une retraite.
Qu'avons-nous obtenu à la place ?
Le programme retraite
et le glissement de la responsabilité des entreprises vers nous
pour planifier notre retraite.
On a pris les commandes, et les risques.
Il se fait que des millions d'entre nous n'excellent pas tant que ça
à investir volontairement pendant plus de 40 ans.
Des millions d'entre nous ne savent pas bien gérer les risques.
Les chiffres sont explicites.
La moitié des ménages américains n'ont aucune épargne-retraite.
Absolument rien.
Aucun plan d'épargne-retraite, public ou privé, pas un centime.
Parmi les gens de 55 à 64 ans qui ont un compte de retraite,
la valeur médiane de ce compte est de 104 000 dollars.
104 000 dollars, c'est mieux que rien,
mais l'intérêt annuel génère 300 dollars.
Inutile de préciser qu'on ne peut pas vivre avec ça.
Avec si peu d'épargne,
les retraites sont devenues une relique du passé
et sans épargne-retraite, des millions d'Américains,
dont beaucoup proches de la retraite, dépendent de la sécurité sociale
pour couvrir leur retraite.
C'est là qu'est le problème.
La sécurité sociale n'a jamais été prévue pour être l'épargne-retraite.
C'est loin de suffire.
Au mieux, ça remplace 40%
du dernier revenu avant la retraite.
Les choses ont beaucoup changé
depuis l'introduction de la sécurité sociale en 1935.
À l'époque, un homme de 21 ans avait 50% de chance
de vivre jusqu'à l'âge de 65 ans.
Il prenait sa retraite à 60 ans,
se mettait à la pêche, embrassait ses petits-enfants,
achetait une montre en or,
et mourait cinq ans après avoir commencé à recevoir sa retraite.
Ça ne se passe plus ainsi maintenant.
Si vous êtes à la fin de la cinquantaine et en bonne santé,
vous vivrez encore aisément pendant 20 ou 25 ans.
C'est vraiment très long pour joindre les deux bouts
quand on est fauché.
C'est quoi le scénario si vous êtes dans cette situation
à l'âge de 50, 55 ou 60 ans ?
C'est quoi le scénario si vous ne voulez pas vous retrouver là
et que vous avez 22 ou 32 ans ?
Je vais vous dire ce que j'ai appris à la dure :
la cavalerie ne viendra pas.
Il n'y a pas de secours,
ni de prince charmant,
ni de sauvetage financier à espérer.
Si on veut tenter autre chose que vieillir pauvre en Amérique,
il va falloir qu'on se sauve soi-même et qu'on s'entraide pour y échapper.
Je suis sortie de l'ombre,
je vous parle ouvertement,
et je vous invite à faire pareil.
Je ne vous dirai pas que c'est facile.
Je relate mon histoire
parce que je pense que ça aidera d'autres à faire le récit de leur propre histoire.
Je suis convaincue que notre force réside dans notre nombre
pour commencer à changer le discours national creux
que l'on entend sur la crise de la retraite,
alors que nous sommes nombreux à être sous le choc et à la dérive.
Nous allons devoir prendre le problème à la base
et créer ce que j'appelle des cercles de résilience.
Ce sont des petits groupes de personnes qui se réunissent
pour parler de ce qui leur arrive,
pour partager ressources et informations
et pour entrevoir un moyen de s'en sortir.
Je crois qu'à partir de cette base, on peut retrouver notre voix,
et sonner l'alarme,
faire pression sur nos institutions et nos élus,
pour s'attaquer à la crise de la retraite avec l'urgence nécessaire.
Entretemps,
et il y a un « entretemps »,
nous allons devoir adopter une attitude de vie frugale,
et couper drastiquement dans nos dépenses.
Je ne parle pas de vivre selon nos moyens.
Beaucoup de personnes en sont déjà à ce stade.
Ce qui est nécessaire aujourd'hui,
plus profondément,
est de remettre en question ce que signifie
de vivre une vie qui n'est pas définie par les choses.
J'appelle ça : « réduire ».
Réduire veut dire comprendre ce dont on a vraiment besoin
pour se sentir satisfait et enraciné.
J'ai un ami qui conduit une épave
mais il va épargner chaque centime pour avoir 15 000 dollars
pour s'acheter une flûte
car la musique joue un rôle central dans sa vie.
Il a réduit.
J'ai aussi dû abandonner la pensée magique,
cette idée que si j'étais suffisamment patiente,
et me serrais la ceinture,
la situation redeviendrait normale.
Si j'envoyais un autre CV,
si je répondais à une autre offre en ligne
ou si je participais à cette réception de networking,
j'obtiendrais le même genre de travail que ceux que j'avais avant.
La situation allait redevenir normale, sans aucun doute.
En fait, ce ne sera pas le cas, et pour vous non plus.
La normalité que nous connaissions fait partie du passé.
Dans cette nouvelle époque,
on va nous demander de faire des choses que nous ne voulons pas faire.
On va nous demander d'accepter des engagements
qui nous paraissent être en-dessous de notre talent,
de nos compétences.
Je dois descendre de mon estrade.
L'année dernière, une bonne amie m'a demandé de l'aider
pour un boulot d'organisation.
Je pensais qu'elle parlait de l'organisation d'une communauté
comme ce que Barack Obama a réalisé à Chicago.
Mais elle parlait de vider le placard de quelqu'un.
Je lui ai répondu non.
Elle m'a dit : « Descend de ton trône. L'argent n'a pas d'odeur. »
Ce n'est pas facile de faire partie de la première équipe
qui défriche cette nouvelle époque de travail et vie.
Les pionniers ont toujours le plus difficile.
Ils précèdent les réseaux,
les sentiers battus et les modèles,
les politiques et les exemples qui montrent comment aller de l'avant.
Nous sommes dans l'œil du cyclone
et il va falloir trouver un moyen de le traverser.
En attendant, on construit des ponts.
Les ponts, c'est ce qu'on fait
tant qu'on essaie d'identifier ce qui vient ensuite.
Les ponts, c'est abandonner la notion
que notre valeur dépend de notre revenu,
de nos titres et de notre travail.
Les ponts peuvent paraître cool selon la situation personnelle
au moment où la crise financière nous a percutés.
J'ai des amis docteurs en science qui travaillent chez Ikea,
qui sont chauffeurs Uber ou Lyft.
D'autres amis se sont mis en partenariat avec d'autres baby-boomers
et s'éclatent en créant des entreprises.
Les ponts ne signifient pas que nous ne voulons pas
construire sur les fondations de notre carrière,
que nous ne voulons pas de travail qui fasse sens.
Bien sûr qu'on en a envie.
Les ponts, c'est ce qu'on fait entretemps,
pendant qu'on cherche l'étape suivante.
J'ai aussi appris à penser stratégie au lieu d'échec
quand j'analyse toutes ces choses que je ne veux pas faire.
C'est une approche que je vous recommande.
Si vous devez emménager chez votre frère pour joindre les deux bouts,
appelez-le.
Si vous devez accepter un locataire pour vous aider à rembourser votre prêt,
ou payer votre loyer,
faites-le.
Si vous avez besoin de coupons alimentaires,
allez les chercher.
Les ONG affirment qu'un tiers des adultes éligibles seulement viennent les demander.
Faites ce qui est nécessaire pour continuer.
Sachez que nous sommes des millions dans cette situation.
Sortez de l'ombre.
Réduisez vos dépenses,
réduisez.
Pensez stratégie et pas échec.
Descendez de votre trône
et trouver des ponts à construire pour traverser les moments difficiles.
En tant que nation, nous avons allongé la durée de vie,
grâce aux milliards de dollars investis dans les diagnostics, les soins,
et la gestion des maladies.
Vivre seulement longtemps, ça ne le fera pas.
Nous voulons vivre bien.
Nous n'avons pas autant investi dans l'infrastructure physique
pour garantir ça.
Nous avons donc besoin d'une nouvelle manière d'envisager
ce que signifie être vieux aux États-Unis.
Nous avons besoin de conseils et d'idées sur comment vivre
une vie enrichissante
avec des revenus bien plus modestes.
Je fais appel aux agents du changement,
aux entrepreneurs sociaux,
aux artistes, aux aînés et aux investisseurs responsables.
Je fais appel aux développeurs et aux perturbateurs du statu quo.
On a besoin de vous pour imaginer
comment investir dans des services, des produits et des infrastructures
qui maintiendront notre dignité,
notre indépendance et notre bien-être
durant les nombreuses années que nous allons encore vivre.
Mon cheminement m'a conduite d'un lieu de crainte et de honte
à un lieu d'humilité et de compréhension.
Je suis prête à rejoindre les rangs avec d'autres,
pour gagner ce combat,
et je vous invite à me rejoindre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)